All right, so, out of this beautiful spread
Yes.
and beautiful bounty,
what are we making today,
and how can we learn from you?
So, it's my own little spin on shakshuka.
Shakshuka is a Moroccan dish.
It's a breakfast dish
with tomato sauce and some eggs in it.
So, we switched it up at the grocer,
and we made a za'atar shakshuka.
So, what we're gonna do
is mix a little za'atar and olive oil,
which we already have mixed,
but I'll add a little bit of olive oil to it,
and we're gonna mix that up,
and then we've got our-
And can you give a little, like,
flavor profile to this spice?
Is it reminiscent
Yes.
of a certain something?
So, za'atar has oregano, thyme, marjoram,
sesame seeds and sumac in it.
So it's herbaceous, but also, the sumac makes it
a little tangy as well.
Mm-hmm.
So it's a little bit of both,
and what we're gonna do,
now that it's bubbling,
we're gonna crack the eggs right in there,
Mm-hmm.
and the za'atar paste
is basically gonna fry up the eggs.
So all I've been thinking about
is crack your eggs correctly on TV,
Oh, my gosh!
So.
I would just-
So, here we go.
I'm not kidding, Edy.
I just did the exact same thing.
I was like, "Oh no, I'm gonna
have to crack an egg."
Don't mess this up.
(Edy chuckling)
(audience chuckling)
So, we're gonna crack those right in here,
and you can see, the eggs are gonna start
bubbling up and frying in the za'atar paste,
and it gives it that delicious crust,
and then we're gonna let that go,
and let that za'atar paste kinda do its own job.
Right in there, look at that. Nice, nice.
I don't wanna let you down, Edy.
I'm gonna do this.
(Edy chuckling)
So,
Okay.
while that's that's doing its thing,
we're gonna get our halloumi going.
So are you familiar with halloumi?
I am a huge halloumi head.
I love halloumi.
So for you that don't know what halloumi is,
it is a cheese that you can sear and cook,
because it doesn't melt.
So we're gonna throw some olive oil into our pan,
and then we're gonna just sear off the halloumi.
And what is the tomato jam?
So, this-
How and where
does that play into it?
So basically,
you would sear the halloumi,
which is why I love this pan that we're using,
and you would sear the halloumi,
and then throw the tomatoes
right in there with the garlic
Look at that.
and let that all cook together,
but instead, we've made it on the side and it's bubbling,
and we're gonna add that right into the pan
once the-
The tomato paste?
Yes, once the halloumi is ready.
Once the halloumi is ready.
Halloumi. Ha-loo-mi.
(Edy chuckling)
So I'm gonna add the other halloumi right in there,
and then just throw this delicious tomato jam right on top,
and the great thing about this tomato jam,
I like to call it a tomato jam, but it's just really
cherry tomatoes with garlic, cooked down.
And do you cut your cherry tomatoes first?
No.
Like in half?
Or do you just let them-
Let them burst on their own.
That's when you know they're ready.
Oh yeah.
Now, we're gonna have-
We've all done some bursting
on our own, here and there.
(Drew chuckling)
(Edy chuckling)
So we're just gonna let that go.
Let it do its thing.
Uh-oh. What happened to this egg, Edy?
I don't know, my eggs are looking.
Oh, what did happen?
What alien
species happened there?
It's like poaching, basically, in the za'atar.
It really is.
So should I grab
the non-alien eggs,
Yes, yes.
and stick them in?
So what we're gonna do is actually,
now that it's ready,
we're just gonna plate up.
Okay.
Yeah.
Do you have a plate?
I do have a plate.
You know what?
I might need a plate.
Also, I might, oh, you know what?
Here.
Yes.
I'm a rebel homemaker.
There we go.
What am I talking about? All right.
What do I do?
So what we're gonna do
is I'm gonna turn this down a little.
We're gonna serve ourself a little of the tomato jam
with some halloumi, of course.
I'm gonna have two pieces of halloumi,
'cause why not?
And then we're gonna put some of the egg
right in here, as well.
So you know that the egg is ready
once that crust becomes crunchy around it.
So, I made myself-
I might be
a rebel homemaker,
Look at that.
That's beautiful.
but I do care about plating.
Yes.
All right, and then the egg.
Move this over.
One of my eggs that doesn't
One of the eggs.
Look like an alien species.
And then maybe a little bit of arugula on top
just for a little green.
A-ha.
There you go, you got it.
Ha! A-ha!
A-ha!
There we go.
Yes, yes!
A-ha!
(audience cheering)
(Edy applauding)
You did it. It's gorgeous.
What are you thinking?
I think I just, still also want a little-
I think I might.
I'm kind of like
a perfectionist about my plating.
I'm a nut-ball in the kitchen,
but I want it to like I want people to be like,
"God, that chick is nuts",
but then at the end, be like,
"Oh, it doesn't look crazy".
That makes sense.
Or it doesn't look so bad.
So it's important to honor
the plating process and the food.
Oh, you and I did take a very different
approach, though.
Yeah.
(audience laughing)
But it's fine.
You can do it whatever way you want.
You know?
(Drew chuckling)
I also think this was the wrong size plate to begin with.
I wanted a full plate.
(Edy laughing)
That's why I portioned it out
like it should be a full plate.
(audience applauding)
Cheers!
Cheers to that!
Cheers to you.
Edy, I'm so grateful
to be sharing this moment with you.
Same.
I'm such an admirer.
I'm such a fan.
Thank you.
I have cyber-stalked you.
You're also an incredible advocate
for your home in Lebanon.
I feel like I've learned a lot
about your home, through your advocacy.
So thank you for all that you do
in your community here in Brooklyn,
Thank you.
as well as back home.
I mean, that's like-
That means a lot
for you to bring that up.
That means a lot, truly. Thank you.
(bright music)